[Music]
you're like obsessed with Ryan Gosling
right yeah I don't think I've ever told
you the story Ryan goling sublet my
apartment for like three months daddy
gos daddy
Goss stayed in your apartment yeah same
sheets
bro I love that you just knew what I was
going to ask yes of course did he whip
the sheets off when he left they just
stayed no here's what he did he he I
think he was dating I don't know who he
was dating the time but they like bought
uh like used bikes yes and they were
like riding bikes around near and but
they were like crappy like crappy crappy
bikes like 20 bucks they might have paid
uh the guy when he when he like stops
staying there leaves the bikes there
like he's doing me a
favor but in truth he's dumping his
bikes
on so you see a hard throb I see like a
dead beat
tenen and uh but I will say this like
when I got there uh there were like
books of poetry and like candles
everywhere so it's like oh this guy is a
this guy is true as good as advertised
yeah like this guy is as good as it yeah
this is what I hope I like to think the
whole time he was just eating Cheetos
and watching reruns of say by the Bell
no I know as a guy you're like he's
probably like an idiot he probably
doesn't and then you get there and he's
like he actually reads poetry yeah and I
bet he cries but in a Manish way yeah
like he cries whiskey and like punches
his chest as he like oh I'm feeling
things and then the drive song Just K
cuts off he just the gloves I got to do
some
thinking